das hat sich komplett irgendwas richtig
kranken entwickele der vater meiner
freundin ist in der band nach richtig
krassen band bestehend aus profis die
für leute die pollen an den
fantastischen vier und noch vielen
weiteren gespielt haben also top notch
und wir sind jetzt auf die absolut dumme
idee gekommen dass ich ja ich der
absolut keine ahnung von musik hat
klammheimlich einen song komponiert mit
klavier
die tage
schlagzeug
[Musik]
percussion und so richtig mit text und
gesang
ja und die band muss es an versuchen was
auch immer auch dabei rauskommt auf
einer bühne zu spielen das problem ist
nur ich kann nicht komponieren
warte mal ich kann nicht mal noten lesen
nach der auftritte schon nächste woche
los geht's dieses video wird unterstützt
von skill scheer
ich habe wirklich gar keine ahnung wo
ich jetzt anfangen soll ich wäre jetzt
aber mal wirklich dummes klingt wie
komponiere ich einen song bring it on
the piano
hier erfahre ich einige tipps wie ich
auf einer ersten melodie ein ganzes
stück aufbauen zum beispiel indem man
manche noten rückwärts spielt etwas
abwechslung bringt indem man eine oktave
höher geht und so weiter also wie wäre
es denn wenn wir als erstes mit einer
melodie anfangen das wäre eigentlich
schon mal sinnvoll sein
wir haben ja im piano hero provinz
einfach kann man mit so einem termin in
einer woche video habe ich ja bereits
das ein oder andere nicht gelernt und da
könnte ich jetzt auch eigentlich mich
daran bedienen und anderen ein paar
schöne klänge ein paar schöne akkorde
mal rauspicken die sich gut anhören was
akkorde übernehmen von einem anderen
lied ja was viele nicht wissen ist dass
es nur eine sehr begrenzte anzahl von
akkorden gibt und deshalb ist es kein
wunder dass tausende bekannte songs aus
den gleichen akkord kombinationen
bestehen das zeigt zum beispiel dieses
video in dem durchgehend die gleichen
vier akkorde gespielt werden und dazu
pokerface von lady gaga let it be von
den beatles no woman no cry von bob
marley und 50 andere chart hits gesungen
werden deswegen ist es auch kein wunder
warum das häufig als songwriting übung
empfohlen wird ich habe jetzt zum
beispiel die akkorde aus dem lied
arbeiters lauf genommen dass sich
eigentlich so anhört
und das dann mit einem eigenen rhythmus
und eigene melodie zu dem gemacht
[Musik]
das hätte schon mal kohle anfang jetzt
muss ich mir noch überlegen wie ich mir
das auf schreibt oder so weil ich weiss
ja nie vergessen und ich kann kein kino
jetzt da ich kann sie aufnehmen ein
computerprogramm ziehen und dann sehe
ich das hier so guitar hero mäßig
vielleicht läuft es wurde besser und ich
habe jetzt noch viele warum probieren
irgendwas gefunden mal schauen
ja also es sollte auf jeden fall übrig
ich versuche jetzt dass man halbwegs
freundlich zu spielen dass da noch ein
pc zu ziehen und dann ein paar fehler
auszubessern so sieht das ganze jetzt
hier am pc auswählen die noten das ist
quasi alles was ich jetzt gerade
gespielt habt okay dass er kommt wird
den wir nicht aus dem takt ich habe
keinen plan
ich google mal wie das programm
funktioniert und so hört sich das alles
auf gewand an
das wollte eine ganze zeit ganz cool
aber das kann sich jetzt nicht
wiederholen wie es eigentlich sein sagen
aufgebracht die meisten modernen lieder
bestehen unter anderem aus folgenden
grundbaustein erstens der worse der
zwei- bis dreimal pro song auf kommt
immer die gleiche melodie aber andere
lyrics hat und die geschichte
vorantreibt der corus oftmals auch huck
oder re frage genannt kommt drei bis
viermal pro song vor und bildet das herz
und ist meistens die stelle von der man
den ohren bekommt mit immer der gleichen
melodie und sich oft wiederholenden
lyrics drittens die bridge in der
meistens eine neue melodie und lyrics
kommen damit die ohren eine pause haben
und man dann wieder etwas gewohntes
hören will diese bausteine werden dann
zum beispiel so zusammen gesteckt wird
ein score usw erst zwei chores bridge
core os 2 x oder irgendeine andere
kombination derselben bausteine aber ich
probier's mal damit
das was ich als bisher gemacht habe ist
glaube ich der börse wurde der koloss
ich setze mich nochmals kein video netz
ich hab ich meine eigene melodie spielt
naja gut egal am ende muss es ja auch er
hier können und ich mache jetzt habe ich
glaube ich
[Musik]
da frage ich mir das gleich mal ein pci
so der keyboarder hat schon mal was zu
tun aber wenn das jetzt so bleibt dann
langweilt sich natürlich der rest der
band also geht haare gitarre stimmt
gut habe
[Musik]
das war ein wilder ritt lasst euch
also ich glaube dass mit der gitarre
stellt sich als schwierig heraus als
dass ich mir dachte ja ok werden jetzt
hier das klavier und da drunter haben
wir quasi die gitarre als 30 seiner zu
hören
[Musik]
ja wir können trotzdem sehr sehr ruhig
für den gt rissen glaube ich aber mir
fällt dazu gerade exakt nicht mehr ein
was noch einen dicken unterschied machen
wir jetzt sind die trucks allerdings
habe ich kein schlagzeug deswegen
probiere ich das mal komplett digital
hier mal eine bassdrum
m
das also wir sagen wir haben mit den
drums ein bisschen diesen chor uster
diesen refrain hervor
mal schauen vielleicht kriegt das ja
auch hin der kick open hat jost hat
klappt sind die grundbausteine von dem
dombret und ich würde sagen die höfliche
noch zu sagen wie sich irgend etwas
brauchbares hat also ok üblicherweise
sind auf jeden beatniks und basting ein
zufall dass mache jetzt einfach mal auch
nicht so aggressiv und gar ein
erstmals näher dazu
[Musik]
ja klar warum nicht die hält knöpfe
jedoch
[Musik]
ich bin cool als ich jetzt auch schon
halb eins morgens saison fertig werden
ich muss jetzt auch nicht baseline dazu
kriegen also eine bassgitarre und dann
noch einen text schreiben so da die
sophie auch darauf singen werden muss
nach diesen text über die gehabt da ich
jetzt mal zum ersten mal sagt jack den
beat von den sonst noch nicht so ganz
alles soll war schon sein als ich
wünsche euch auch sehr cool
von startplatz eins definitiv ich finde
die drums irgendwie bis sind vier meldet
zu sein
ja das mache ich nicht
der hat mich der mich auch rhythmisch
irgendwie bisschen verwirrt das
verstehen der songwriter wie ich meine
melodie im kopf wenn man es wird finde
ich das doch gut ich nicht so
schwierigen text zu finden wenn wir
keine sorgen machen zu lassen
meine logik war so songtexte sind
vergleichbar mit gedichten nur eben mit
musik das ziel ist das gleiche mit
reimen stilmitteln und vor allem einer
eingängigen geschichte gefühle zu
erwecken ich entscheide mich dazu die
wunderschöne geschichte des kleinen
prinzen aus der perspektive des
erzählers zu erzählen und hier die mir
wichtigen kerninhalte mit tollen wörtern
zusammen zu fassen und mit der richtigen
anzahl an selben zu einem stimmigen text
zusammenschnüren ist schwer und so ist
das zwei uhr nachts als zuviel den
sonntags zum ersten mal singt sechs
stunden bevor es morgen losgeht richtung
studio und band ich müsste ja eigentlich
franken
zeigen will
[Musik]
jedoch kann er so hoch sinkt ja okay ich
mag tatsächlich den refrain ich finde
ich ganz cool
bei uns ist es so denn
also ich will es nicht jetzt meisterwerk
aber wie gesagt ich finds halt schon
lustig dass ich das halt nach irgendwie
nach musik anhören bereit
richtig schön gesungen also ist ein hit
oder einmal irgendwie kommentare
eigentlich anmerkungen
das war das was ich wollte nicht sagen
so wie du es uns geliefert hat und zwar
genau wie es geliefert habe
[Musik]
das ist schon mal gut
hh
die chance und die haben große hoffnung
[Musik]
haben
also für wen war das jetzt die wildeste
erfahrung
ich glaube ich glaube auch den
schlafsack
das ist von peter wirklich so
ungewöhnlich wie ich es nie spielen
würde ja aber von daher ist es natürlich
eine super herausforderung vor allem
jetzt was macht man daraus wie würdest
du dein spiel normal ist schon deutlich
anders aussehen langsamer wahrscheinlich
wenn du was machen
vielleicht ist und ich würde mich mit
dem bassisten zusammentun also können
wir super gut wenn das halt wenn er
jeder einfach zu wenig kreativität
einbringen kann wie es nur geht ich
würde mit dem bisschen mehr luft geben
weil zeile anzeiger klebt und so und
damit ein bisschen mehr atmen kann was
in der musik passiert würde ich zum
beispiel in der strophe würde ich quasi
die courts bzw
die will ich ihm half time versuchen zu
machen das ist ein bisschen mehr auf
lehrer und dennree freiwillig aber
tatsächlich so lassen generell also das
hast du gut gemerkt dass da ist der
kleine prinz ist es von vorteil wenn man
die story kennt ja sehr schön etwas die
erste mal was nettes ich finde aber
diese melodie am anfang mit diesem die
finde ich schon schön dass ihr dies
eingängig die nüsse die würde ich immer
wieder zitieren vielleicht nicht die
ganze zeit aber die würde ich auf jeden
fall bringen weil die ist teil von
dieser idee die eigentlich hat ist für
jemanden der das nicht professionell
macht also war ich positiv
zwischendurch mit 50 jahren machen würde
wird vielleicht was brauchbar ist lasst
uns doch direkt mal in dem mit dem
gerufen mit dem tempo genau und mit dem
intro mal starten das wohngebiet und wir
spielen uns dann immer so langsam ein
bisschen genauer wollen wir so einen
tick weiter runter nehmen personen
refrain auch mal auf
und machen eine gewohnte vorjahr aber
lasst uns doch die strophe mal in der 63
[Musik]
also das hat sich komplett irgendwas
richtig kranken entwickeln
das ist einfach so also das fühlt sich
aber von außen an das wird dann von
selber passiert obwohl das natürlich
jahre lang hat es den jetzt nach welcher
hafen und dann ist die frage wie der
referent
ich hab nicht was ich für die ja da
müsst ihr müsst ihr in den rat fragen
naja stände somit doppelt so schnelle
spiel mal ich hab kein plan
also woher wissen sie das alles und
jetzt seht ihr die finale überarbeitete
version des songs
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die soße
wo
die karte
unfassbar krass mehr kann ich dazu nicht
sagen auch wenn meine version noch sehr
holprig und rhythmisch eine katastrophe
war haben wir news & magic kids uns in
einem extrem harmonischen und coolen
zusammenspiel gezeigt die echte profis
in rekordzeit eine richtig starke nummer
daraus werden lassen können den ganzen
song findet ihr jetzt in der video
beschreibung verlinkt auf dem kanal der
band unbedingt mal rüber denn zum ende
hin geht erklärte gesang noch mal
richtig ab und lasst ihn gern ein
kleines dankeschön dafür dieses tolle
erlebnis
ich liebe es mit seinem selbst bald zu
bringen und zwar wo wann und wie ich
will skater ist dafür perfekt und hat
tausende klassen für fast alle themen
wie zb film fotografie produktivität
selbständigkeit und viele mehr aber
nicht nur für anfänger sondern auch auf
profiniveau vor kurzem bin ich auf die
klasse produktivität vor quer durchs von
thomas franke stoß gerade kreative
menschen die sich gerne in kreativen
prozess verlieren und sich von ihrer
inspiration treiben lassen haben oft
probleme mit disziplin und produktivität
wie man diese beiden dinge als kreativer
oder selbstständiger leicht meistert
erfahrt ihr über den link eine video
beschreibung über die übrigens die
ersten 1000 von euch eine
probemitgliedschaft von skills premium
bekommen es gibt keine werbung permanent
neue professionelle klassen mit dem man
fast alles lernen kann und mit einem
jährlichen abo gibt es das ganze für nur
8 euro im monat wenn ihr jetzt mal
nächstes video nicht verpassen möchte
abo und glocke ihr wisst bescheid und
dann sehen wir zunächst mal wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]